senior political analyst Brit Hume joins
us good evening Brett Shannon okay so
let's talk trade and tariffs the
president says today after the ripples
and the backlash that came last week
both domestically and internationally he
says we are not backing down but we
understand a final announcement a final
decision is yet to come where do you
think he goes well my guess is that he
will go through with the ones that the
tariffs that he's announced he may
soften the effect on some of our allies
as president george w bush did but this
is i think these these tariffs on steel
aluminum going to happen the question
then really becomes whether they and
themselves will cause them as much havoc
as some are predicting my death I very
much doubt that the worry is about what
happens after that whether in fact the
retaliation meets with retaliation again
from him and pretty soon we have a trade
war there isn't anybody that I know of
that thinks the trade war is a good idea
and despite the president's comments
about trade boards being easy to win
they usually end up as being a loser for
everybody involved
and my guess is that the president will
pull back from that and that this may
all be another example of the president
you know blustering talk and threats and
so on and it ends up being less than
meets the eye but we'll see yeah he said
he's not even sure there will be any
kind of trade were based on his
announcement that we expect within the
next few days meanwhile we heard from
Democrats I talked to several of them
last week who were actually very
supportive and happy about this idea
most of them in that Rust Belt area
that's been hit really hard with a
number of blows to the steel industry
and when we talked about worries from
the agricultural community from farmers
from other industries of within the US
they said you know what it's time for
the steel industry to get a break and we
can't worry about everybody else if
we're gonna save these towns in these
mills but it's certainly setting up some
very interesting showdowns well remember
this Shannon about about steel steel has
been a troubled industry in the United
States for about as long as I can
remember it there are serious
disadvantages competitive disadvantage
as it still has with other countries
around the world where they can produce
the stuff much cheaper and they too have
big industries that
create that product and they got to do
something with them and that creates the
situation of glut which we now have
which is affecting the the u.s. steel
industry it is a strategic metal there's
no doubt about that you have to have the
capacity to get steel when you need it
if there's an international conflict of
some kind but this is this has been
tried before
as John Roberts noted earlier President
Bush tried this with steel and he ended
up lifting them after a while because
the retaliation was strong and it didn't
really work I'm dubious as to whether it
will work this time but remember this
about this president Shannon this is
something he basically promised to do
during the campaign and say what you
will about Donald Trump he does try to
keep his campaign promises and I think
in this case he's trying to redeem
another one how far he wants to go with
it obviously is what we're all watching
well and Sarah Sanders said repeatedly
and again today that no one on the hill
and there's been plenty of pushback from
the Republicans should have been
surprised because as you said he's been
talking about this issue and making
these promises for years last week one
of the Senate's top Republicans John
Cornyn said that they were going to have
hearings on the tariff issue because we
want to exercise our important role of
oversight of the executive branch today
the Speaker of the House Paul Ryan also
pushing back saying we may need to flex
some of our muscle when it comes to this
issue and limits on the president's
power how do you think that all shakes
out well this is a case where the
president is at loggerheads with the
conservatives in the Republican Party
which is to say most of the Republican
Party Republicans have not been in favor
of anything but but free trade wide-open
trade for a very long time there are few
exception to this but not very many and
the president now finds himself you know
in company with a certain number of
Democrats from Rust Belt states who are
obviously trying to protect their their
their local communities and their local
industries but I don't think its support
is very wide on this and obviously if
certain American industry start to get
hit on this it will evaporate pretty
quickly
all right Brit Hume always great to chat
with you thank you